The Andrew File System was a bold new experiment in the CS department at CMU.
The intent was to enable students across campus, to be able to walk up to any
workstation on campus, and start using it. All
the files stored in a central server on
the local area network. Will be accessible in
a safe and secure manner from that workstation.
The assumption is that the network itself is untrusted. In this lesson we will
use, the Andrews system as a case study to see how Private key
cryptographic infrastructure can be used for the
security and authentication of such a system.
The focus in this lesson is a distributed file system being made available to
a user community. And the year is circa 1988, and the state
of the computing at that time looked as follows. Local area network
and client workstations connecting the servers and the local disk on the
workstation serve as efficient caches of
files that maybe downloaded from the server.